this week we've got sneak peak least
light and you're hired
all right first story yeah you're
waiting to get interrupted huh yeah it's
unlike okay all right I said we're
unpredictable true we never interrupt
you but take it away Tiffany all right
first story this went viral this
conversation here this is what it looks
like I will read it it says this is a
conversation with the customer service
so anti-climactic this is what it looks
like a letters because I know you guys
so let me read it to you yeah let's do
it
museum like this is the Constitution
don't care I do like the conversation it
says can you see the messages I'm typing
before I send them and the customer
service said we get a preview smiley
face is there anything else I can help
you with at all I'm really glad you
found the bolts and then the person says
that doesn't seem right to me creepy at
the least and then the customer service
says gives us a little bit of extra time
to look up information smiley face can I
help you with anything else today so it
turns out that customer service
representatives that you're chatting
with online can see in real-time what
you're chatting you mean what you're
typing oh yes sorry would you type right
so they see the preview like the feel
like if they see in real-time what
you're typing that's perfect so a lot of
people are like damn what why do we have
this fake ass send message to make us
believe that what we're typing is
private to us and so that's like this
whole thing now where it's like that's
creepy they should just tell us that
it's in real time because sometimes on
when I do get mad because my food didn't
show up for two hours and [ __ ] I'd be
like you [ __ ] delete delete
delete delete it dude I saw that last
time maybe that's why they gave me a
full refund cuz they're like oh this guy
went from you [ __ ] [ __ ] to
I really need your company to be on time
that's a big difference so they're like
all how does it make you feel now that
you know that they saw in a real good
yeah me too I'm not even gonna bother
present said I'm just gonna leave it in
the [ __ ] in the [ __ ] type area I
know you can read this [ __ ] oh
you should write that good yeah I know
you can read this [ __ ] [ __ ] damn well
yeah I mean a lot of people were just
creeped out yeah I mean I think they
should just let people know that's
what's happening yeah dude cuz that's
privacy man you can't just do that like
act like you're not doing that I think
it's just like lying yeah it comes off
sneaky you don't mean like it's like
what's the purpose of it not that that
anyone really cares yeah
but it's that person's point like why
even have said message if they could
already see an additional one but it's
like it's like just disclose it in the
beginning oh you know cuz when you're
typing things out before you hit Send
it's almost like thinking things out
before you talk you're working it out in
your head but if I just didn't do that
and I was just like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I mean you [ __ ] face I mean hey
man imagine text messages worth like
that and all the [ __ ] that you would
like already wrote out and then that
you've erased like all the [ __ ] that you
would all but error you lose friends are
just like what are you [ __ ] pissed
and I'm gonna go in on someone and then
I'm like and I write it out I'm like no
no and then i erase it and then I like
type it in the right way I just got to
go back and look for a red squigglies I
don't know I don't even do that I just
said I think we we deserve that I just
send that out to you cuz we're flawed as
humans you know we've made mistakes so
if you because we've all done that yeah
you have you should have the right if
you write something to like before you
send it to send yeah delete it and be
like you know what that's not right let
me write this I want like I've written
like [ __ ] do you suck my dick but then
I'm like I can't send now I'm like dude
everything hurt my feelings I do that
for her comments sometimes you type out
all the comment and you're like
and you're like Billy okay it's not
worth the elderly oh you wrote you
respond no I don't press then oh
comments are so many times like I'm just
like [ __ ] it and I press that you do you
guys we think you guys need to come s
from time to time there yeah and they're
all of you guys mmm-hmm yeah see I don't
I don't
it's good that's that's better so like
no I can't because because there's
always gonna be trolls yeah well how
about if you want to interact and see
like how your fans been doing your ass
problem with it right so it's like tough
we cannot read comments and then be
happy or but there's still like the
other 90% that are really nice yeah they
want you to read it and so what that
mean it's hard to like grace past the
negative ones and then after you see
yeah it's like you see like a white
ceiling in it but then you it's all
white but then you focus on that one
marker like you know cuz sometimes you
read a comment and you know I'm saying
you only recognize the Negev and
sometimes you're not even aware of how
your day is so you can already be having
a shitty day that just and it's all like
usually like you're pretty level-headed
but then you're just having a shitty day
no I'm just going through cons I'm not
the non said that's true they're really
effects you know when the probably
wouldn't affect you just yesterday or so
because they could get personal man it's
like looking at a beautiful flower patch
and then there's a decapitate a person
in the middle yeah yeah you can't just
only look at the [ __ ] flowers you're
gonna know I had two capitate a person
yeah
where's the balance D and it keeps
sticking out and you have to reply to
that decapitated thing yeah yeah do it
so do you read all like maybe 10% of
carried all of them that's too much we
300 comments did you read all of them
no I stay away especially from JK videos
yeah you just stay away I don't mind you
can use that comets are the most
hilarious because one video it'll say
like [ __ ] Joe and Dave they're so
[ __ ] stupid and the next one dude
David he's always right good wild good
we got some funny-ass fans yeah yeah so
like [ __ ] I'm just like I was a good one
yeah I like abilities what is and I like
it because it keeps me updated on what
they do like or like what works and what
they want to see more of so it's more
like the majority of it is like fan
interaction and understanding my own
business so it's not really get to see
the responses or things like never they
come to my personal stuff that's and
I'll see it but like in the actual
videos I'm just like thank you but we're
only talking about the negative parts
right I think like David said there's
90% of beautiful field yes the beautiful
field of roses except for that one to
capitate a person but it's like yeah
there's a there's a lot of what do you
call it like information that can help
you create content and and know what the
the public wants now you're making my
you just put the light bulb in my head
now I could probably it'll save you from
thinking what should I do next cuz
there's gonna be like 20 comments like
Steve do this next video we want you to
bring so-and-so back you know like
you're right man all right Mac stories
talking about comments and likes and all
this stuff this mommy blogger was under
fire I hate her posting that one her and
her kids is the leak you can't look okay
is that one of her kids is the least
light that [ __ ] is so true though her
name was Katie
she's a DIY parenting blogger what's the
point of that she has like five kids I
think oh let's guess which way she hates
that's a big family that she hates this
kid it's just that she pointed
okay so first like the least popular one
it's so rude it's the one on the far
right yeah it's just that one it's this
one
no the top left this guy Oh what cuz I
already hate the one on the far right
how did you know at the top laughs I
don't know I just picked whatever oh I
thought you heard about this um yeah so
then she posted this what did she say
the birthday post for her kid and so she
was like oh you know I'm thankful for
Weston my West is the best baby all this
stuff right he loves this he loves that
and then so that was like the first
paragraph of her caption and then she
writes these two paragraphs what does
she say so for that second paragraph it
says guys I'm gonna be perfectly honest
Instagram never liked my munchkin and it
killed me inside his photos never got as
many likes never got comments from a
statistical point of view he wasn't as
popular with everyone out there maybe
part of that was the pictures just never
hit the algorithm right part might be
because he was the baby for a very short
amount of time before
LJ came along and then Max and then Ella
and people like babies I say all that
because I want to believe that it wasn't
him that it won't my god my
insufficiency caused the statistical
deficit ah she lives on herself yeah why
does she secret validation her kid
through Instagram returning her family
into a business that's so sad it's not
genuine like it's for its for likes it's
for likes it's man as she's using damn
as props knowing she's aware of those
like you got no one trips on that right
yeah you don't go oh this doesn't have
as much you know what the sad thing is
to like I'd like I've done videos where
I have talked about like how much of a
far social media is right so what people
put out there is only what you get to
see because they choose to let you see
this yeah so people can create whatever
the [ __ ] they want persona wise and
whatever yeah and when people say that
is like oh well these kids is like no
I'm not talking about kids I'm talking
about adults too you know what I mean
and but the worst thing about adults are
at least kids can recognize it that it's
them adults think that they're better
than these kids that are doing it but
they do it more than they do oh my god
yes on Facebook I see only adults
out there that I'm like I don't think
kids right now whatever do what you're
just doing it's like oh people that are
blaming but blaming Millennials for
social media and all this share words
but they are worse yeah they're [ __ ]
worse so an example would be like oh my
god I can't stand my co-workers they
pissed me off or whatever and I'm like
wait why are you saying that doing full
of like like why here or oh my god I
just finished crying for the longest
time and I'm like why the diary like who
cares about all this [ __ ] oh I can't
wait to eat this and it's like a basic
salad or something I'm like what are you
doing like get a [ __ ] life stop
living here is it so weird because like
the reason why I think it's funny is
because there's they have their posts
are them also [ __ ] on younger people
for doing the thing that they're [ __ ]
doing so you can't [ __ ] on these kids
when you're you're actually better at
what they're doing than they are doing
it yeah I mean so it doesn't make any
sense it's like in this post here she
ended it with yes I wanted to clarify
that I revealed this feeling because I
know one day he will see the number oh
my god or in that his value is not in
online approval as if you make it happen
like yes she's making the values the
kids he doing it that's what everyone
said like she the one putting it out
that crazy
Ryan's that are posting on her stories
trying to like explain herself like you
know what though some sleep late I don't
know how you can have five kids and be
on social media this much what that's
her like dude she's a mommy blogger well
she can if they're going to school cuz
then for that stretch of time that
there's a look there's like a lot at all
different ages to like they're not
school kids oh I mean we don't know what
she what how often she's posting and all
that that's true three of those kids
don't look like they're ready for school
that one on the far left looks like he
owned the business though on the bottom
left one what those elbows between his
thighs yeah that's what successful is
[ __ ] he's a successful businessman
that's so sad man this lady's just like
I get it it's her business and that's
what she's focusing on but I'm just like
you can't make your family this lady all
she's analyzing it too much
headlines before because she she
revealed that she didn't understand what
the big deal about 911 was they realized
people died it's just the [ __ ] number
you type when there's an emergency so
she thought no no no so she loved it the
building's what they were Porsche she
thought that the buildings that went
down were empty that people didn't she
thought they were demolition why did she
get that idea in the truck in the trade
Salvage
this girl is in college in that this is
somebody who is so far removed from
reality like she only looks at like
affection love and just worth do numbers
right so that that alone just if I
already knew that about it that doesn't
surprise me that I hope they don't take
away her kids cuz this lady is not right
no no this is a mental yeah you're right
there's something going on that sounds
real kids are gonna be [ __ ] up dude
he's trying to approach this in a like
I'm being vulnerable shut the [ __ ] up
dude the way I feel no you're exposing
exposing us do you know what she needs
to do disable or account and just be a
regular mom yeah yeah disable her
account and just live live a regular
life well she can't do it go go with
mommy I mean that's the only way dude or
else she's gonna keep this is gonna keep
happening I don't I don't give a [ __ ] if
if Tyga gets anything yeah in like the
only reason why he's ever in our vlogs
it's cuz we vlog our life and he's in
our life all the time the only reason
why he gets so many views is cuz he's
two as [ __ ] if that baby was ugly zero
we have three other kids that they
haven't gotten that many likes
so I'll even expose them to this right
yeah I know that [ __ ] ha yeah see y'all
even in the closets like a biker and
checker they're all gonna talk about you
the youngest one he just found me the
cute one the other three I think this is
the kind of person that takes her kids
to events and things not cuz she really
wants to but for [ __ ] social media
yeah
she's a [ __ ] pilot moaz to all of her
kids yeah she's like oh my god you're
gonna get a loose tooth oh my god
imagine all that like somebody get let's
pull this tooth out oh I'm sure I'm
trying to show you that I'm vulnerable
it's like what first of all you said
that post is for your kid so why is it
why it was have to do it exactly you
[ __ ] just lied you didn't know the
[ __ ] you're talking about you cut bag I
don't like her
alright last story here this guy
photoshopped a fake ad and it
accidentally made that company go viral
to the point where the company offered
him a job in marketing that's hot yeah
oh that's cool that's what I always
trying to do did you see my fake out of
the Trojan condom standing out for me
anything did it go viral
no but the Instagram told me that I have
to like tag my my contact my sponsor and
it was even real so this is the real ad
it's myself lender it says just got
declined for not having credit gets off
lender self lender South lender helps
you build credit while saving money each
month my credit score is up 43 points so
that's the original ad oh damn I need
that yeah so then the photoshopped ads
of this just got declined for not having
credit get self lender how the [ __ ]
would I know what that is don't catch an
attitude with me [ __ ] I'm trying to
help you build your credit okay that's
nice so true what the hell is self
lender that's fast money that's a little
went viral
have you guys seen this [ __ ] ad on
Instagram dude it's like the saddest
thing I've ever seen in my life it's
like god I don't want to go out to the
movies with my girlfriend I don't have
any cash well did you know with this app
you could just get you could get your
paycheck early on I was like I for a
movie ticket it's the saddest thing I've
ever 11 dollars
damn that is pretty sad and then it's
like the girl his girl is like yeah
[ __ ] sad there's gas there's popcorn
there's maybe dinner before but maybe
they shouldn't do that just stick to
Netflix this yeah
buddy what the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah is it
geared toward high school students that
only have like part-time minimum-wage yo
you could [ __ ] it that's bad yeah that's
like getting movie tickets on layaway I
was like a really good looking at a
really good looking girl and then she's
super proud of him for getting [ __ ]
loading up at my hand dude no wonder
this country's bankrupt
she was [ __ ] wild yeah a lot of
people we're tweeting this this out the
photoshopped one because they thought it
really was from South under they're like
hell yeah we love it when a PR team is
actually like reaching out to the youth
in like a way to youth is that what that
it was rewarding well um it was a
conversation that went viral that was it
well if we add you first of all with the
ad and then they photoshopped a fake
conversation oh good you left everything
the same like sponsored self Lander
everything is the same except these two
responses which is how the [ __ ] would I
know what that is what is self landing
mode thing yeah something about like to
build your credit oh maybe just open
these loans that you already have money
for us you could probably pay it back
slowly so you're not going into debt but
then by having a loan open you could
probably build your credit that way yeah
let's play something like yeah and so
they're saying the company was like yeah
you know we we thought that the best way
was to hire the person that made this go
viral and maybe they can't he can come
up with something else that would
continue to bring attention to the
company I like that they reached the
youth without insulting them usually
ever listen to light ads on power 106
they're trying to reach to youth where
they're like a fool what car payment do
you have and they're like oh it's only
for that ninety nine dollars a much like
what ninety nine dollars the mug that's
[ __ ] crazy homes and they just made
it seem broken gets but is that what we
think that's true though dude worried
you're [ __ ] locked up you can stall
for the car
insinuate all these other crazy thinking
le local ads are pretty bad though it's
pretty funny cuz you think he's
exaggerating and he's not even in [ __ ]
it's like it's like a toe lock girl and
stuff like that call 1-800 - a little
bail bond that's real that's this is
like the commercial right it's like this
I love it like this oh my car is broken
down or didn't you know about [ __ ]
Henriques [ __ ] body shops in Boyle
Heights don't ignore the pound of
cocaine in the backseat all this extra
[ __ ] in there all the time
love the [ __ ] fake cars out of the
crashing [ __ ] dude it makes me laugh I
like the dealership ones where it's like
got no credit bad credit you got an old
money you have bad points on your
drivers your why do all negative [ __ ]
it's like this guy it sounds like you
shouldn't be driving [ __ ] you got
DUIs all that's gone worries man
well you go sell you a car and it's like
well still insure you this person
shouldn't be driving
dude you should try to hire that person
for like sound types peril JK news a
very amazing man no I want to hurt the
writers with you guys yeah that'd be
amazing dude that would be kind of cool
that'd be cool right
[Music]